foreign
what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to talk about
some weird Indiana Jones five
controversy where the director himself
he's firing back that is Sir director
James Mangold a fantastic director but
before that first order business John
how's it going I am good sir how are you
I'm doing well I'm doing well ladies and
gentlemen whip that like button whip
like Indiana Jones secondly I want to
give the regular viewers a heads up here
that uh we're gonna be out of town from
the 12th through the 20th keep that in
mind if anything massive drops might not
be around for it but we are prepping
many videos in advance so yeah you know
we're just gonna do do our best but
we'll keep things in a regular schedule
come uh come January but in the meantime
let's talk about this piece of news
here's what we'll do we're going to
Tarantino this a little bit all right
first I'm going to read to you guys what
James mangle tweeted out they're going
to talk about what he's talking about
and then explored a little bit because
uh it's just kind of uh it's a little
ridiculous A little silly but uh I'm
enjoying it enjoying watching the chaos
of lucasfilm it's It's always a it's
always amusing because lucasfilm's
reputation is just so like up and down
like the internet with lucasfilm is one
one amazing journey but anyway here's
what mangle tweeted out it's a
three-parter tweet thread here we go one
more time no one is taking over or
replacing indie or donning his hat nor
is he being erased through some
contrivance and he never was not in any
cut or script but trolls will troll
that's how they get their clicks and
please don't exhaust me pointing out how
once in a while a troll is right even a
blind squirrel finds a nut now and then
all one has to do is look at set photos
and interviews and you get enough info
to make wild guesses about a movie plot
the diff between trolling a-holes and
everyone else is they're trying to make
money off your feelings about other
films and culture War politics they push
controversial guesses as coming from
sources to Gin of clicks Let It Go end
and here's my favorite part the top
reply is I am very ticked that the
director is trying to cover up all this
with damage control because what is
leaked out already and how they want to
ruin Indiana Jones get Kathy Kennedy off
the set off the movie making and get
this done right do not give that other
character immediately just completely
disregarding now what is James mangle
talking about exactly right let's unpack
this so I'm going to talk about an
ending of a leak and now I'm going to
talk about it because according to James
mangled it's all [ __ ] that's why I'm
willing to talk about it because he is
trying to make it abundantly clear that
is just plain and simple not true so I'm
going to talk about what he's what he's
describing here I don't know if you've
heard of what this supposed leak is but
it's it's silly and if it happens man
that is it's a real crap but it doesn't
sound likely especially with the
director himself going out of his way to
say it's not happening so what mainly
happens in this leak is that some of us
have been thinking that it deals with
time travel like I heard dial a destiny
you see this flashback version like does
this deal with time even I thought that
but what this leak surmises that there
was like test screenings how James
mangle has already denied that any test
screens already took place in this leak
it's that Phoebe Waller Bridge Through
Time Travel hijinks ends up pretty much
going back in time and you see like a
montage of the Indiana Jones movies and
it's her so she has like taken the place
of Indiana Jones through like the
Raiders of the Lost Ark Temple of Doom
through the it's it's this basic like
reworking and rebooting and it was like
oh it was actually I think her name's uh
Helena Helena Helena Helena the whole
time it was her the whole time so they
rewrite the history of Indiana Jones
with making it her and then she would
take over the franchise is basically
what it sounds insane and ridiculous and
what I love about how everyone just
started immediately buying it is because
because it's lucasfilm because it's
Disney and someone came up with the most
brilliant idea of like what is the
wokest [ __ ] we literally
replaced our iconic male Hero characters
the female actor and he's had to deny
this like several times to me it's like
okay even if that is the current ending
you gotta change that because no way now
I wouldn't even be on board with that
that just sounds like an insult and is
someone like James Mangold who loves
Indiana Jones he's a director who wanted
to do this because he he reveres his
franchise no one with a real reverence
for Indiana Jones would want to erase
the history of Indiana Jones yeah that
is just batshit to me it was already
hard enough to give him a son the last
time I know right and the second he put
on that hat everyone lost their minds so
I can highly doubt like this sounds like
like the most trollish troll to ever
troll like unless the movie drops and
this really is what it is this seems
like the most obvious like joke I know
like I I think like there's got to be
some type of time travel element I do I
do believe that that's gonna be in the
movie some way but that ending itself
I'm like no come on like the fact that
directors literally spelling it out for
you that there's it's just not gonna
happen we are not going to do that and
yet there are people who still believe
these other click bait sources
it's just like no come on guys you're
just looking for something to get upset
about and to rail against because what
we we just got the trailer so there has
to be a Resurgence of the anti-hype wave
right I mean the thing dogging this
movie the whole time is this Phoebe
Waller bridge is going to replace
Indiana Jones and it's like Harrison
Ford isn't going to be Indiana Jones for
much longer longer let's just enjoy him
while he's here yeah like could I see a
version of this movie ending where they
decide to give the franchise or do some
type of spin-off thing with Phoebe
Waller Bridge's character sure or why
why not yeah I I could see that
happening they have a show in
development that I believe is about uh
Mary and ravenwood's Dad or some [ __ ]
that's what we need so we wanted to
always know about what was up with
Marion's Papa oh honestly the adventures
there I don't think they're gonna do
something where they are right no one's
gonna be cheering and hootering and
hollering for that and no one would want
that and I feel like James Mangold is is
smart enough to know that would be the
end of his career as a director reviewer
like proceed once five drops he's gonna
come out and announce that he is the
director of Deadpool three and it's
gonna take place after Logan and Logan
is back alive hey Kathleen Kennedy if
I'm not mistaken she's one of the
producers of the original uh Indiana
Jones films right like she was she's
partnered up with Spielberg on those
movies I don't think she would want to
slight the Legacy well it insulted in
some way yeah and you also still have
involvement from folks like Steven
Spielberg who I doubt are going to let
you just drive the ship into the ground
regardless of what your thoughts were on
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull yeah like
there's so many people around who would
be able to catch something as outlandish
as that and I think that as much as we
are in a phase in an era now where we
are doing tons of de-aging we're
bringing actors back we're ignoring
sequels and we're being very modular
with our franchises it just doesn't make
any sense especially for the way they've
been talking about this up till this
point for the enthusiasm Harrison Ford
has had for it up until this point like
nobody's Behavior surrounding this movie
suggests what this leak this potential
leak Howard Harrison Ford vehicle yeah I
know why would he sign on to this
freaking movie because he clearly
doesn't have to and it seems like the
one franchise like he doesn't seem to
care as much about Han Solo as he does
about Indiana Jones and I feel like yeah
like this wouldn't be the send-off for
him if that was the case the truth like
you wouldn't literally erase his Visage
from the history of the character as a
fitting and loving send-off to him you
want to be mad if you're buying this
yeah I mean I feel like it's really easy
to make anything under the lucasfilm
like already the Disney umbrella it's
really easy to make an enemy out of but
lucasfilm specifically that section is
so easy to rile people up because they
ruined Star Wars and we will never
forgive them no matter how many andors
they make I don't have any other things
that Indiana Jones is technically a
Lucas film yeah I oh I forget that
um but anyway all right guys yeah I just
thought this was like ridiculous and uh
stop buying into it just stop stop
buying it to do okay all righty well
what do you think do you think they're
gonna go through through that ending
still yep
um leave your thoughts down below go
ahead subscribe leave a like you can
check out Indiana Jones 5 trailer
reaction and uh we'll talk with you all
soon
[Music]